Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
In this video,we're talking about which dataclass solution is best for your situation.
I already have awhole video explaining what dataclasses are.
But for those of you that haven't seen that videoyet, here's the gist.
Throughout the process of writing code,
you often create classes that arebasically just containers for pieces of data that you've collected.
It's a good thing to makethese containers
because they can really help people understand the meaning of your code.
Take alook at this simple init function.
All I want to do is store an int of float in a string.
But here, youcan see that n, f and s are repeated three times for each of them.
This is already more repetitionthan I'd like.
And it's only going to get worse if I want to add things
like a hash function or acompare function to this class.
Dataclasses help me get rid of all that boilerplate.
Here's thesame class.
Notice that there's nothing repeated in the definition of the class.
I only have n, f,s and their type hints once.
But this built-in dataclass decorator isn't the only solution thatoffers similar functionality.
We're going to look at the different features that each solution has.
And then also compare how fast they are and how much memory they use.
If you're looking for theclassic no frills dependency free solution for most cases,
then just stick with the built-in dataclass.
In my last video, the only reservation that I had about using the built-in dataclass decoratorwas that it didn't support slots.
Well, I'm using Python 3.10.
So, now it's just this easy in orderto use slots instead of an instance dictionary.
The first really good alternative to dataclassis attrs.
Sometimes attrs is a little bit more verbose than dataclasses.
But it also comes witha little bit more functionality.
In addition to supporting everything that dataclasses supportincluding slots,
attrs also supports variable conversions, data validation
and default factoriesspecifically for mutable arguments.
Here I specify a converter which is just int.
So, anything youpass in, it'll pass into int before storing it.
There are a bunch of built-in validators likechecking if something is an instance of the right type at runtime.
And you can specify defaultarguments and default factories for mutable things.
Even though you see me using dataclasses in mostof my videos,
I actually use attrs more in real life.
attrs just has that little bit of extraflexibility that can make a big difference in a real project.
The next three alternatives arejust based off of tuples.
Whenever I talk about dataclasses, I always get people asking:
Whycan't I just store this information in a tuple?
Well, of course you can, if you want your object tobe treated like a tuple all the time.
Tuples are printed in a sensible way by default.
And they'rereally fast and they're really memory efficient.
If you just want to store three pieces of data,then a tuple is a good choice.
If you want to make your code just a little bit more readable
so you don't have to access everything by index,
you can use a namedtuple.
A namedtuple from thecollections library is a tuple.
It's a tuple that gives names to each of its elements.
And that meansthat in addition to accessing things by index, you can also access them by name.
This is a huge winfor readability.
But this syntax for creating the class is a little bit cumbersome not easy toread.
And there's also no types mentioned here.
If you want the exact same thing as a namedtuple
but also with static type information available,
then you should use NamedTuple from the typinglibrary.
This NamedTuple is a thin wrapper around the other one.
It's still a tuple and it stillbehaves exactly the same as the other one.
The benefit though is that this way of defining theclass
is much easier to read and it also leaves a space for the type hints.
If you care about statictyping at all, then you should always prefer this NamedTuple over the other one.
The main drawbacksto using any of these dataclasses that are based off of tuples
is that they are based off of tuples.
Tuples are immutable. So, you can't change any of the elements after a tuple is created.
You'd haveto make a copy of the tuple with a different value in one of the slots.
That means, you basicallyhave to pay the cost of an instance creation every time you want to change something.
The othermain reservation you should have about using these tuples is type safety.
You're not going to get anykind of error if you try to mix this kind of tuple and a raw untyped tuple
even if you do operationsthat semantically might not make sense
like using plus or less than.
This is somewhat mitigated ifyou're actually doing static type checking.
But you should still be aware.
I might as well include dictin here because this is what a lot of beginners do.
There's no type safety or even type informationat all.
And accessing things by string is really really error prone.
I know it's really convenientto write something like this
especially for testing or the first time that you're looking ata problem.
But in my experience, using a dictionary this way is too error prone for my levelof comfort.
If this structure of having an n, f and s is something that's going to be usedmany times throughout your application
and not just confined to a single function, then youshould really be using a class.
A very slight upgrade in readability from a dictionary isto use a SimpleNamespace.
SimpleNamespace is just like object
except it allows you to setattributes on it at runtime, whereas object doesn't
Its use is primarily to avoid this anti-pattern
where you just create a class for the sake of creating an empty class that you can putattributes on.
And by popular demand, the last choice that we'll be looking at is pydantic.
Now originally, I wasn't even going to talk about this.
But in my dataclasses video,I got a ton of comments about pydantic.
pydantic is a very opinionated library built fordoing a specific task:
Parsing
By default, pydantic will try to convert things into these types
whenyou construct this object or set an attribute.
And it will check those types at runtime.
One of thecommon problems that you get when you're parsing data
is that the data you're reading might notbe valid
or it might not be in the right format.
So, converting things at runtime
and checkingtypes and checking conversions at runtime
makes a lot of sense for the specific task of parsing.
However, doing all of this at runtime is a huge waste of resources, both time and memory,
if parsing isnot your goal.
If this data structure of an int, float and a string is something that's internalto my application
and my application is primarily responsible for creating these data structures
and modifying them and doing whatever with them,
then it would be a huge waste of resources to doruntime checking.
It would be better and probably even easier to do static type checking
and tocatch any type errors before the program even runs.
So, in my mind, I don't really see pydantic modelsas an alternative to dataclasses.
They serve a very different and specific purpose.
If you aredoing parsing, like potentially parsing json from a web api,
then pydantic is a great choice.It's very good at what it does.
It's just not a general purpose thing.
And we're going to see thatperformance hit in the graphs that are coming up.
Okay, time to take a step back and look at theoverall picture.
First up, speed.
How long does it take to create an instance,
how long does ittake to access an attribute on the instance
and how long does it take to set an attribute?
Theseare the creation times for each of the different classes in nanoseconds.
So, these are all very small.
However, you can see pydantic is losing by a lot because it's doing this runtime checking.
That's ahuge price to pay.
So, let's go ahead and zoom in on all the rest of the things.
There's a little bit ofvariability. But there's two pretty clear winners.
Obviously, the built-in tuple and built-indictionary get preferential treatment in the language.
Tuple and dict are written primarilyin C.
Everything else has to go through Python.
That means tuple gets to sit nicely around30 nanoseconds.
And everything else is taking about 300.
If you care about this difference inperformance,
then you might need to be writing a C extension or just using C directly.
So, if you'reprogramming in Python,
I'd say that all of these should be good choices
as long as each onehas the features that you're looking for.
Alright, let's look at getattr and setattr.
The first thingyou should notice is that
the getattr and setattr times are much less than the instance creation times.
But that doesn't mean that you shouldn't worry about them.
We often get and set attributesof a single object many many times.
So, these little times can add up.
Here's the picture forgetting attributes.
Basically, everything takes the same amount of time except SimpleNameSpace and pydantic.
It's a similar story for setting attributes.
Let's go ahead and zoom inso that pydantic isn't dominating everything.
Here, everything that's mutable, of course,is taking about the same amount of time.
You can still choose to use an immutable thingeven if you want to make changes to the objects.
Just remember that if you do that, thenwhenever you want to make a change,
then you actually pay the creation cost notthe setattr cost.
That's because you basically have to create a new object that has to change datain it.
So, unless the changes that you're making are extremely infrequent
or if you're using araw tuple whose creation time is just that low,
then you should probably just prefer to usesomething that's mutable in the first place.
On to memory usage. Everything is in bytes andlower is better.
Everything that used less than 200 bytes is something that is tuple or slots based.
Everything that took more than 200 bytes used an instance dictionary.
If you're programming inPython, you're probably not too memory constrained.
But if you're really creating a lot of objects,
sometimes it can be useful to save a factor of two.
This is a big place where attrs and data classesshine.
You can choose to use slots if you want to conserve that extra memory
or you can choose tohave the convenience of an instance dictionary.
Finally, here's the feature matrix to helpyou decide which one is right for you.
In my opinion, the best overall choice isattrs.
The most convenient choice is dataclass.
And the best choice for record like data isthe capital NamedTuple.
Of course, if your task is specifically parsing, then use pydantic.
That's all I've got. Thank you for watching.